things like this needs to be
unforgettable there needs to be special
Maksim Chmerkovskiy and Peta Murgatroyd
confirmed they're expecting their first
child together
PETA shared the happy news on Instagram
posting this photo with Max and her
growing baby bump she captioned it we
couldn't be happier
baby Chmerkovskiy is coming sources
first told he GE the couple was
expecting last month and Maxim popped
the question to PETA in December they
opened up about their engagement to Ichi
that same month it was not like one
thing that I knew it was it was that I
couldn't see myself with anybody else so
he's like literally the love of my life
and that's that's it but I told I'm not
planning anything else I'm done Maxim
tells People magazine quote I can't wait
to provide this baby with the tools to
become a beautiful kind person and
they'll have the best sneaker collection
the pairs bundle of joy is due in
January which PETA says gives them six
months to prepare for their summer 2017
wedding